when you think of Disney movies you
think of safe wholesome fun for the
entire family
but based on this list maybe instead you
should think about phone sex sad orphans
and the literal embodiment of death
appearing in a man's eyes shortly before
he meets his grisly demise that rhymed
you know for kids here are some of the
most controversial moments hidden in
Disney movies all the dead moms the
number of dead or missing Disney moms
are staggering just a few of the disney
movies featuring missing mommies Beauty
and the Beast Pocahontas
Fox and the Hound and of course Bambi
[Music]
what gives
apparently Walt Disney had a devastating
personal reason why his films were so
heavy-handed with this form of despair
Disney producer Don Hahn explained in an
interview with Glamour that in the 1940s
Walt was so successful that he bought
his parents a house he had the studio
guys come over and fix the furnace but
when his mum and dad moved in the
furnace leaked than his mother died he
never spoke about that time because he
personally felt responsible because he
had become so successful that he said
let me buy you a house it's every kid's
dream to buy their parents a house and
just through a strange freak of nature
through no fault of his own the studio
workers didn't know what they were doing
yeesh still it's not as though the dead
parents and his movies are getting eaten
or anything right family matters the
Three Little Pigs might have been most
afraid of the big bad wolf coming to
blow their houses down but the 1932
short film Three Little Pigs also
included a gentle reminder of the other
big threat to the pink trio safety the
human diet take a look at the picture
labeled father hanging on the wall yep
that's just a length of sausage links it
doesn't stop there either not long after
we see another photo of their piggie
Papa this time as a big ham hock
meanwhile in her portrait maar pig was
show nursing 7 piglets rather than just
those three before of the character
siblings end up in the slaughterhouse of
dear old dad probably that's all pretty
gross for a kid's cartoon right but at
least it wasn't something truly
disturbing like a guy dressed as Santa
Claus inspiring kids to dollar phone sex
line wait a second the spanker Claus
this he had a pretty big oopsie on his
hand of 1994's the Santa Claus in the
film Tim Allen Scott Calvin was given a
phone number with which he could reach
his ex-wife during his Christmas visit
with their son and so he said one it who
spanked me I know that number as far as
singers go it's pretty tame but little
did Disney realize the number was
actually an active sex hotline that
charged callers by the minute the
Seattle Times reported that several
children reportedly dialed in and racked
up some huge phone bills as a result of
their curiosity the dialog was later cut
from DVD releases for the movie and
change someone 800-pound in television
airings
the same not that one 800-pound isn't
any less suggestive but at least it's
not enough numbers to actually connect
to a phone sex line so Disney
accidentally got some toddlers to call
dirty chat lines big deal it's not like
they inadvertently filled their animated
movies with all kinds of sexual
suggestive images and dialogue alright
good kitty bad center between the
topless photo that found its way into
the rescuers and the stranger not to me
that fans discovered in the Little
Mermaid Disney movies have no shortage
of accidental sexiness case-in-point
1992's Aladdin and 1997 circulates
legend has it that Aladdin disguised as
a prince there's something pretty insane
while attempting to court Princess
Jasmine on a balcony take a listen
pound did he say good teenagers take off
your clothes
listen again actor Scott Wenger who
voiced the character has insisted he
never said the words so many heard but
the soundbite is still pretty convincing
despite his denial the scripted line for
the moment in question was reportedly
supposed to be come on good kitty take
off and go which would make sense since
Aladdin's in danger of getting eaten by
a tiger but whether due to a sound
mixing flub as some suspects or an
intentionally implanted bit of
subliminal messaging that is just not
what the utterance sounds like meanwhile
in Hercules fans looking for the more
sublimino shenanigans or privates
everywhere from an alleged man doodle on
Hercules baby crib to one of the muses
seemingly but not really going commando
viewers have filled the internet with
so-called proof of sexual deviancy
sprinkled throughout the movie but have
mostly come up with nothing well except
for maybe this one scene where Hercules
fights a center
[Music]
those are balls
really can there be a mistake nope
you're looking at pause okay fine we'll
chalk that up to the animator getting a
little careless with his pencil but
seriously it's not as though Disney is
intentionally cramming adult subject
matter into kids movies right
Gaston sees death when Gaston finally
goes by the wayside as in getting pushed
off a cliff after trying to kill Belle's
true love in Beauty and the Beast we
never see his ultimate fate even though
it seems pretty clear that he's met his
maker but upon closer inspection the
scene was even more grim than it seemed
in the close-up of Gaston XY's a pair of
skulls can be seen flashing in his
pupils a detail deleted from VHS release
but seen in the DVD version the fact
that Disney removed it from the first
home release of Beauty and the Beast
proves that someone at the studio
realized that this is actually pretty
messed up for one the fact that it only
lasts a frame or two seems to prove that
all those crazy conspiracy theorists are
right that Disney is sticking subliminal
messages into movies for another it's
just creepy on its own do kids really
need to know that Gaston is actually
seeing the face of the Grim Reaper
himself at the clearly plunges to us do
robably not just make the candlestick
dance and sing again okay be our guest
be our guest put our service to the test
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which controversy
you think was actually blown out of
proportion
[Music]